tonight is a unique show for me because
it's the first time in 17 seasons that I
have missed a show no doubt Ryan
Seacrest is the hardest-working man in
show biz but sometimes the man needs a
break I really had to cash in on my very
first sick day but a friend and mentor
Bobby bones was kind enough to fill in I
love this show to me it's part of my
life things got down to the nitty-gritty
on Mondays American Idol as the
remaining contestants performed all-star
duets and vied for a spot in the top 14
I think that the contestants are just
feeling so grateful and blessed to be
able to have this experience contestant
Alejandro Aranda was paired up with Ben
Harper
[Music]
Alejandro and Benner from nearby
hometowns and it turns out
Alejandro left a lasting impression on
Ben and he didn't even know it
I had heard him in my family's shop and
I've heard so much music in that shop
over over in my whole lifetime his
playing is so singular that I poked my
head out of the shop off-key working on
instruments I'd hear him planet-like
yeah that's that he's got a temper hand
I remember his playing is there crazy
wait coda not only delivered impressive
vocals he also served us with some
fashion you look great doing it there's
security outside and a guy about my size
like what it was rapport and the other
day I was just like can I try that on no
way and then I tried it on I was like I
look good and he let me use this jacket
and now
[Music]
naturally Demetrius Graham performed
with Lukas Graham and got the highest
praise from judge Katy Perry
he's the male Beyonce on this season of
American Idol has served up some
undeniably talented stars in the making
et was with the judges in January where
they shared their approach to giving
contestant feedback I think having a
year behind you you understand when you
may want to give somebody maybe one more
opportunity and sometimes even last year
some kids we let them through based on
their original audition well now this
year we know they're gonna get chewed up
there's no need to prolong you guys are
being a little more I don't cut throats
the right word but a little more it
changes I mean there's no um we know
what a top ten looks like yeah and we
know that it's amazing
[Music]